Закуті в бетон, завалені сміттям, забруднені будівельним і промисловими відходами.
Так виглядають десятки річок у Києві та інших українських містах.
Серед них була й Почайна - ріка, в якій, за літописами, князь Володимир хрестив Київську Русь понад тисячу років тому.
Почайна - така ж стародавня, як Борисфен - Дніпро. Біля Почайни було засновано Київ.
Ще до того, як з'явився Київ, на берегу річки Почайни були стародавні старослов'янські поселення.
Тому саме у водах річки Почайни, це ми знаємо з літопису, проводився обряд хрещення киян за часів князя Володимира у 988 році.
Коли радянська влада почала розбудовувати Київ, зокрема район Оболонь, річище Почайни перекрили лінією метрополітену.
А пісок для намиву житлового масиву добували з озер водної системи Почайни.
Це історичне культове місце отримало бюрократичну назву "Відкрита дренажна система Опечень".
Після цього річка занепадала впродовж десятиліть, допоки у 2015 році на старих картах її не помітила краєзнавчиня Аннабелла Моріна.
А коли побачила це місце наживо - стан річки був плачевний.
І відразу заходиш, а там не просто сміття. Грабельками тягнеш і витягуєш просто великий такий мішок будівельного сміття.
І під кожним деревом було, ну я так не скажу, але там були сотні пляшок. Під кожним кущем, кожним деревом. Там величезне було звалище.
Краєзнавчиня поставила за мету відновити це знакове місце. Після цього почалася боротьба за ріку.
Київська міська рада у 2016 році планувала провести магістраль залишками русла Почайни.
А територію поруч з нею забудувати. Аннабелла Моріна три місяці ходила до будівлі КМДА на страйки.
У результаті план забудови не затвердили. Тоді активістка вирішила, що почати треба з відновлення історичної пам'яті.
У 2018 році ініціювали та провели довгу процедуру перейменування метро "Петрівка" на "Почайну".
Для того, щоб люди, яким не дуже цікава історія, вони не знаються на річках, не копаються у документах, вони запитували "А що це за Почайна?"
Гуглили. І знаходили інформацію про Почайну, нову Вікіпедію, яку я заповнила.
І взагалі всю інформацію про те, як ми боремося, і що тут поруч взагалі-то є парк.
У результаті, громадський проєкт "Почайна" затвердили.
Тепер тут тривають роботи з розширення річки, вивільнення її з бетону, й облаштування парку навколо водойми.
А гирло річки навіть отримало статус пам'ятки історії й археології національного значення.
Однак справа не тільки в історичній цінності річок.
В умовах глобального потепління у містах стає дедалі спекотніше, і з'являється дедалі більше теплових острівців -
нагрітих забетонованих ділянок, у яких температура вища, ніж середня по місту. А водні об'єкти - це природні кондиціонери мегаполісів.
Річки й озера охолоджують повітря довкола них, а також збільшують вологість.
Щоб якось змінити цю ситуацію, у природі, у містах відновлюють природний ландшафт. Підіймають річки,
поруч з ними створюють зелені зони, парки, і формують такі вже холодні острови, якими людина може пересуватися містом.
За словами Аннабелли Моріної, нині у Києві налічується майже 40 річок та струмків у занепаді.
Більшість з них знаходяться у структурі дощової каналізації.
Це означає, що до них зливають води з автомобільних доріг - з піском, брудом, дрібним сміттям, бензином.
Одна з таких водойм - ще одна історична річка - Либідь. Тривалий час недоброчесні підприємці зливали до річки свої відходи.
Однак завдяки старанням активістів комунальні служби почали очищати Либідь - встановлювати очисні споруди і штрафувати компанії.
Утім, засновник ГО "Водний рух Київщини" вважає, що цих дій влади недостатньо.
Це все такі першочергові заходи з реанімації водного об'єкту, а не реальні кроки з перетворення річки Либідь,
яка раніше була приміським та міським публічним простором, у знову ж таки публічний простір у межах вже мегаполісу.
Мета водних активістів - перетворити річку Либідь на інклюзивний простір, до якого могли би приходити і люди з інвалідністю, і мами з дитячими візками.
Для цього потрібно облаштувати водойму. За підрахунками Антона Пузаня, якщо відновити й озеленити вільні простори навколо річки,
то загальна площа зелених зон вздовж Либідь буде приблизно 65 гектарів. Однак спершу необхідно визволити річку з бетону.
Понад півтора року в Київській міській раді лежить документ з технічно-економічним обґрунтуванням реконструкції річки Либідь.
Цей документ, фактично, в деталях прописує, чому річку варто відновити, що це дасть місту.
Однак, за словами активіста, профільні управління не підписують документ, без якого неможливо почати ревіталізацію річки.
На думку Пузаня, місто саботує реконструкцію Либідь.
За словами виконувача обов'язків директора комунального підприємства "Плесо",
яке відповідає за благоустрій водойм у Києві, відновлення річок - процедура не з простих.
А Либідь - це один з найважчих інфраструктурних об'єктів міста.
Неможливо, якщо ми беремо до прикладу Либідь, частину цієї річки, бо з цих 12 кілометрів неможливо
здійснити в одному місці лише 300 метрів гарної краси, а в деяких ділянках залишити аварійний стан.
Тому наразі у нас відбувається затвердження нового технічно-економічного обґрунтування до схвалення всього проєкту,
а він передбачає 12 черг на суму більш ніж 2 мільярди гривень.
Савицький стверджує, що питання річки мають розглянути у першому кварталі цього року.
Тоді справді цікаво буде поглянути на рішення міської влади, адже,
згідно з чинним генеральним планом Києва, деякі ділянки Либідь мають бути закриті дорогою.
Взагалі парадокс - біля станції метро "Либідська" Либідь можуть закрити дорогою зверху. Оце реально буде по-київськи.
Аннабелла Моріна каже, що до неї регулярно звертаються люди з різних областей з проханням допомогти ревіталізувати водойми.
І хоча Почайну можна назвати "історією успіху", активістка каже, що більш доречною буде назва "історія успішної боротьби".
Нам постійно забирають кошти з парку, постійно щось роблять з роботами:
то тендери не проводять, то підрядники якось гальмують, незрозуміло чому. Ми працюємо в авральному режимі.
Взагалі-то я вам чесно кажу, нічого не робилося б, якби не наша громадська організація.
Тому що досі нам кажуть, а навіщо нам на це витрачати кошти?
Історичні об'єкти й зони рекреації не відновили би, якби не старання активістів.
Але досі у деяких місцях є ризик забудови. То чому київська влада так мляво підтримує мешканців у питаннях благоустрою?
Це диво, це диво посеред міста. Це якість життя. Розумієте?
Коли ви просто живете у цьому місті, а потім збираєтеся, кудись їдете, Ізраїль, Єрусалим, кудись на Захід, щоб відчути це диво,
ви не розумієте, що диво - воно ось, поруч з нами, просто поруч, до нього можна доторкнутися.
І ось це диво було у сміттєзвалищі, завалене, закинуте, забуте. Ну так не можна робити…